Okay guys, officially welcome to today's call, it's February 11th, 7 a.m. and today we're
going to be talking about closing on the first call.
Really really quick though guys, just a couple things I want to cover.
First of all, if you're not in the Rank and Rent Academy, if you are in this group, you
have free lifetime access as long as you're of course a member of this group, you get
access to the Rank and Rent Academy.
There's nothing in there that you're not going to get in here, this is where you should spend
your time.
However, I will tell you that there's some people I can see right now that are on this
slide that are taking advantage of the things in that group.
Every single Monday at 7 a.m. I go live and I do a Q&A.
Every single Monday.
Now, I will tell you there are things that I refuse to cover in that group because those
people, the ones that are not in this group have not paid for that knowledge.
For example, yesterday we had somebody ask a question about ads and I told them, hey,
you want to learn ads?
You got to pay the piper, you got to pay me, who's paid the piper?
So I'm not going to cover ads.
But there's a lot of other stuff that we cover and so if you guys have questions, you guys
want more FaceTime with me, you guys have paid to be here and so you get access to that.
It's funny, that call is actually dominated by Digital Landlord students so it's amazing.
It makes me happy because I'm able to help you guys from this group inside of that group
as well.
Okay, so that said guys, that is every single Monday at 7 a.m.
If you do not have access to the RankinRent Academy, message, not Francesca, message Ashley,
she'll get you access.
Okay?
A couple quick things about the RankinRent Engine tool.
First and foremost, if you don't know what that is, go to RankinRentEngine.com, it is
the only tool that you need for this business.
You do not, number one, you do not need any tools to make money.
Okay?
Just going to say that out front, you do not need any tools to make money.
I was able to cobble about eight different tools together and I was able to make my money.
But it was a pain.
I spent a lot of time, I spent a lot of effort, I actually spent a lot of money trying to
figure it out.
But I want you guys to know this is not something that you have to do.
It does make things a lot easier.
Doing due diligence.
I was talking to somebody yesterday that was doing, that is in RankinRent Engine.
They're like, yeah, I've already looked at 50 cities, 50 cities, you know how long it
takes to look at 50 cities?
It takes about 30 minutes.
When you first start, probably takes an hour.
But let's say you get good at it, it takes 30 minutes, 30 minutes times 50, do the math.
That's how long it takes to do 50.
This guy just busted them out, okay?
But on the business of Rare, a couple things that you should know.
Number one is there, if you go in, you log in, there is a user metrics dashboard that
is now live.
You can see your progress.
You can see your, you know, did my revenue increase, decrease, clients, all this different
stuff.
It is, it's a great like snapshot of your business.
So that's live.
That is a new feature or a new view that we've added.
Also, I've said this a few times with the backlink analyzer 1.0 is live.
When I say 1.0, we are going to be beefing that up.
We're going to be looking at that for, we're going to be able to, we're going to allow
you guys to be able to look at the backlinks of your competitors from different views,
not just the root domain.
But for now, you can go and you can jam in the root domain of any of your competitors
or any website at all.
And you can go and take a look at the backlinks, okay?
So the backlink analyzer 1.0 is live.
And then one other cool thing, we're trying to keep everything into one place to make
it as easy as possible.
So you guys can have your, your browser open, you have rank and rent engine, you have Google,
you know, you're doing some, some searching on different cities and, and that's it.
You don't have to have a million different softwares open that are all talking.
We're also adding the, the lead value calculator inside of rank and rent engine.
Now I, for those of you that were on yesterday on the rank and rent Academy call, I thought
it was completely live.
We've just sent it into production.
So within the next week or two, that will be live.
Okay.
Anyway, just want to give you guys some updates on that.
It's exciting.
We're making changes.
We're moving.
And anybody that has any recommendations, anything they'd like to see done to that tool,
please email me.
My, my email is nick at digital landlords.com.
You guys can send me an email, send me a, Hey, I would like to see this done.
I'd like to see it do this.
Like for example, we had somebody yesterday from this group that was asking about a quick
little duplication button.
So I take that, I forward it over to Ryan and we can jump on that as soon as possible.
So guys, I'm super excited about that.
We've brought that to you.
That is somebody from this group, Ryan Dalton, who not only build a software, but he's scaled
up to a hundred thousand dollars per month in less than two years.
And just in case anyone's wondering what his numbers are.
So Ryan Dalton, by the way, everyone should, should give Ryan some, some love in the comments.
I know he's not on this call right now.
He's, he's probably got a million things going on, but a dude went from zero to a hundred
K a month in two years, kept his job.
Okay.
Also as a family has a regular life.
He's not just like, you know, let's say Elon Musk that just got divorced three times.
He's kept all that.
And they built rank and run engine on top of that, which is unbelievable.
So his breakdown, he's making a hundred thousand bucks per month.
Eighty six thousand of that is purely Legion.
So he's making over his run right now is over a million dollars a year just on lead generation.
The remaining 14, 15,000 that he's making is a combination of SEO and some PPC management
on some ad stuff.
Okay.
The way I always look at it, guys, is if somebody else is out there that can do it, somebody
else out there that bleeds red, you can do it.
Okay.
That's the way I always look at it is somebody else can do it.
I can do it.
There's no difference between me and Ryan.
There's no difference between me and anybody else.
Differences is they're figuring, they figured out how to use leverage and how to focus on
one thing for a longer period of time.
That's it.
So that's exciting for me when I ever, I see anyone that's way ahead of me.
If I see someone that's making a million dollars a month, well, then of course it's possible
for me.
Okay.
So anyway, guys, that's the updates on Rank and Run Engine.
For those of you, because I have one or two people every time that message me, I'll drop
this in the chat.
We have a discount code for anyone that wants to check that out.
Let me go ahead and drop this really quick if I can find my browser.
There it is.
New landlord, discount on rare.
All right.
With that said, I want to, I just want to say one thing and then we're going to get,
I'm going to get Kyle on here.
We're going to be talking about closing on the first call.
I want you guys to think for just a moment, okay, about a time, whether it was in this
business or it was just a time in your professional life or maybe it was just in your regular
life.
But like, I want you to think about a time when, and Kyle Patton, Mr. Frickin' 6'9",
I want you to do the same if you're listening.
I want you to think about a time that you were just humming.
Time was on your side.
Everything was clicking.
You guys know exactly what I'm talking about.
It's like you're excited.
It feels like you're making deals.
You're closing deals all over the place.
Everything's going your way.
Obviously, it's not easy, but you're just, you have the energy, the excitement to keep
going because things are happening.
You're seeing progress.
Everything's just clicking.
Okay.
Again, preferably if you could think of a time in this business, I can think of a time.
That's 2020 for me.
Okay.
But that was the first time I really, really felt it.
And I want you to ask yourself the following questions because this is what I've been asking
myself all of this year.
Okay.
Number one, have you stopped doing the things that got you to where you are today or that
got you to the success that you are thinking about?
Okay.
Have you stopped doing those things that got you that success?
That's question number one.
This is rhetorical.
You can answer if you want.
Secondly, on the flip side, have you started doing things that you weren't doing when you
had the success?
Example, you weren't watching Netflix every single night.
Now you are.
I want you to legitimately think about that.
Have you stopped doing the things that got you where you are today or that got you to
that success?
Have you started doing things that you weren't doing when you had the success?
So guys, the reason I'm bringing this up is I'm talking to myself because at the end
of last year, I realized that the very things that allowed me to create two seven-figure
companies in three years, literally all the basic little tiny things that I was doing
that got me the success of creating two seven-figure companies, I had stopped doing.
I slowly stopped doing last year and it's embarrassing to say, but I have to own it.
It happens slowly over time.
You stop doing your weekly planning and all of a sudden you stop doing your company meeting.
Then you start doing this.
You start going out on Tuesdays or going out on Thursday, Friday, and Saturday instead
of saying, hey, I'm just going to go out on Saturday, I'm just going to go out on Friday.
For me, 2020, I was super scrappy.
I was hustler.
I was willing to do things that were unscalable.
I was willing to jump on a sales call at 7 a.m. on a Saturday morning.
I actually chose to schedule a sales call every Saturday morning at 7 a.m. just to get
my butt out of bed and just to get me in bed Friday night.
I was willing to jump on sales calls at 11 o'clock at night.
I was willing to miss events.
I was willing to give up golf and pickleball and all these hobbies to get the deal.
I was scrappy, man.
That was what I did.
I was reading 10 pages of a good book.
All these little things that got me into this success, I had completely stopped doing.
It became very apparent just two months ago in December.
I just looked at my life.
I took inventory.
I'm like, what am I doing?
I stopped doing all of those things.
I had started watching Netflix during the week.
I'd started spending time during the workday doing hobbies when I should have been working.
I started taking meaningless calls that weren't getting me closer to my goal.
I started going out on the weekdays instead of just the weekends.
Guys, on January 1st, I made a commitment.
I'm like, I'm cleaning this up.
I am done.
I'm going back to the basics.
I went live yesterday and I told you guys this, but guys, January, and shout out to
Kyle who's going to jump on, he crushed it.
We had the biggest month we had in over 12 months, probably further than that, but we
January than we had all of 2024 in any of the months of 2024.
By the way, my internet looks a tiny bit glitchy.
I apologize.
We're going to just roll with it.
So guys, don't forget what brought you the success in the first place.
Do not forget, and I'm not trying to be motivational, whatever.
I'm just speaking to myself.
Don't forget those things that got you the success in the first place.
It's all those little things that add up.
I promise you that.
So with that said, let me get Kyle on really quick and let's talk about closing on the
first call.
Real quick, David Dale, is Rankin' Red Academy separate from Digital Landlords?
David Dale, yes.
Rankin' Red Academy is separate from Digital Landlords.
Rankin' Red Academy is basically like the equivalent of our old Facebook group.
And by the way, you can message Ashley, you can be a part of it, you can go and build
the community, whatever, but you do not need Rankin' Red Academy.
If you're looking at spending time in Rankin' Red Academy, and here, this is a trillion
times better, right?
The only reason I'm talking about Rankin' Red Academy is we have a live call on Monday
7 a.m.
If you want some extra time with me, you want questions answered from me, jump on 7 a.m.
MST.
There's a link in the calendar section inside of the Rankin' Red Academy, and you guys can
go and access that, but don't for one second think that you need access to that.
It is free for you guys, but I would rather you spend your time here, because this is
where all the juicy stuff is.
Kevin Mija's on, Nick Kudlick, another St. George guy's on, what's up, dude?
Laura Shepard's on.
Kyle Patton, what's up, bro?
What's happening?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Amazing.
Okay, Kyle, you're going to give me 13 seconds while I go close my door before you guys keep
hearing my kids.
Hold tight.
You know the drill, bud.
Go ahead and welcome the people.
You know, this is not my, dude, just sit here and talk in front of people that I can't see.
But what's up, everybody?
If you got sales questions, start dropping them in the chat.
All right, bud, don't worry.
I'm back.
This is not Kyle's cup of tea, so give him a shout out.
This is my cup of tea.
Kyle, I promise you, you start doing this regularly, bud, it will become your cup of
tea.
I don't think so, man.
So guys, Kyle, let's see a couple things about Kyle.
Let's give it for anybody that doesn't know Kyle.
You should know Kyle because you spoke with him to get in this call.
If you didn't, you're one of the rare ones that talked to me, maybe talked to Francesca
because Kyle was on a hunting trip.
But Kyle, how long have you been doing sales, Kyle?
Since 2015.
2015, he started doing door to door sales.
Was it two years you did door to door sales?
Yeah, two years door to door.
Two years door to door sales, then since then, since 2015, all you've done is sales.
Right.
Yep.
And you've sold everything imaginable, short of like magazines and like shoe cleaner, right?
Anything and everything.
Yep.
Yeah.
So just to kind of give you guys a little bit of an idea, Kyle, we sold alarm systems.
Then we sold a software that we pre-sold a software that never became a software.
So that is impressive in and of itself that we sold something that never was anything.
We didn't know at the time.
Then from there, we tried to sell, what was it?
We tried selling SEO services, some paper lead, lead gen services.
Then Kyle and I had like a falling out.
Long story.
We'll share that one another day.
It was good.
Kyle went and where did you go work?
What did you go do sell?
Software for storage facilities.
Yeah.
Kyle went and sold software for storage facilities.
But even before that, he was selling like those cartoon infographic things, right?
Yeah.
Why draw?
Don't forget about this, bro.
You sold those two.
Dude, Kyle has sold everything.
Finally I was able to convince him in, what was it, 2022 to come back to the promised
land.
And here he is.
Guys, Kyle is an amazing resource for you guys.
The good thing about Kyle is he has a very different sales style than myself, where I'll
say things that can maybe get under people's skin or maybe a little bit too, they're a
little bit on the edge.
Kyle, I don't think, have you ever made anyone upset on a call?
I try not to.
I don't think so.
I'm sure there's been a couple, I've ruffled some feathers, but it's pretty rare.
Yeah.
I like it because for a lot of you guys, it's way more relatable to the way that he sells.
And he's actually, so obviously you guys know he's the one that brought you guys in here.
Kyle has brought in, how many students have you brought into this program?
Just over 500 now.
Just over 500.
So we have like, what, close to 800 students, right?
Something like that?
Yeah.
So close to 800.
So Kyle's brought more people into this group than I have.
So Kyle has in the last two years has done far more sales than I have done.
So anyway, I just want you guys to know that back story, to know that he is a very credible
person when it comes to sales, he's been, I bet you he's done more sales calls than
I have at this point because he's done so many, he's doing multiple per week.
So anyway, let me just kind of set the background.
And by the way, Kyle, just for everyone to have an idea, like you didn't grow up doing
sales.
What you did before sales just to paint a picture.
Yeah, I grew up working kind of on a neighbor's farm and then worked at Cal Ranch in high
school and then painted houses for like six years, worked for a fencing company.
So pretty much all physical, physical labor, manual labor kind of jobs, nothing, nothing
within sales.
Yeah.
When I met Kyle trying to convince him to do door to door, he was doing house painting.
So he was just a regular like blue collar dude.
And the only reason that I knew he would do well is we had a mutual friend that was like,
hey, you should hit my buddy up, Kyle.
And I could just tell Kyle, I'm like, dude, if this guy is willing to paint houses, then
he's going to crush it at door to door sales.
And I remember he was like pretty apprehensive because I don't, has anyone in your family
ever done sales or anything like that?
No.
Yeah.
And it's like a taboo in Utah, you know, it's like you serve a mission, then you go
do door to door sales and everybody thinks door to door sales is just a scam.
So that was like my biggest hesitation.
Yeah, I still, Kyle made me drive up to like four hour drive, like two or three times before
he finally agreed to come and do door to door sales.
So dude, let's do this to start.
This would be fun.
And by the way, today we're going to be talking about closing on the first call, getting someone
on the zoom, not letting them off, getting a yes or no.
But Kyle, let's from what you can remember.
So we recruited Kyle back in 2015.
And we were like, Kyle, come out to Vegas, come out to Henderson, Nevada.
Let's go do some sales training before we just go to Arkansas.
So Kyle comes out.
Kyle, do you remember the first deal that you landed?
Yeah, that old guy, Russ Russell, you never forget the first deal, you know what I mean?
So I just remember I put Kyle in this neighborhood.
He was burning doors, dude.
I mean, you went through like three neighborhoods in three days.
Oh, I was just cooking.
He was just calling me every day.
He's like, yeah, I finished the neighborhood.
I'm like, bro, there's like 57 homes in there.
What do you mean you finished the neighborhood?
So finally on Saturday, he gets in this house with this old guy.
And I can't remember what happened.
Somehow I came over the house, dude, and we we we wield and deal, dude.
It was like it was like one of those deals you get on, you pitch at a thousand bucks
a month.
You end up doing it for like five hundred a month and your ads are four hundred.
But you got the deal.
And that was Kyle's first deal.
And he went on to make some great money for the next two years.
And then here we are.
So anyway, guys, let's talk about this.
When I first started doing door to door sales, and I'm sure you were the same, Kyle, I would
get the objection like I want to think about it.
Leave me with your card, all that kind of stuff.
And I remember like when I first, first started, I was like, OK, that sounds good.
You'll call it.
So you'll call me tomorrow.
OK, sounds good.
And I take the card and they're like, yeah, Nick, you did such a good job on the presentation.
Like if I can give you a rate or review, I'd love to talk to your manager, Kyle.
How accurate is that?
What?
Like, is that the same thing that you experienced right when you first started?
Yeah.
Yep.
Nonstop.
When we started doing this, like the equivalent would probably be like, well, it sounds good.
So I'm going to talk with the team and I'm going to get back with you.
Right?
Yep.
How many of those deals do you close, dude?
Like, would you say percentage wise, if when somebody says, let me think about it, I'm
going to, I'm going to check the I got to check the numbers, whatever the thing that
comes out.
It's always I want to think about it.
What percentage just letting them right off the hook?
Would you say that you close like you do close some?
Genuinely speaking, if you let everyone off the hook, there's going to be a small percentage
that you do close.
But what do you think that percentage is?
Yeah.
Probably like 5%.
5%.
And you know what the worst part is, is that that 5% ruins you.
Right?
I get you thinking like, oh, that guy came back.
I'm just looking.
I think Sean's on here.
Sean and Gina, I know they're going to comment because they were one of them that ended up
coming back.
But it's very rare.
It's more often they either go here, you know, give you the whole pitch of why they're not
doing it.
100% man.
So there's a book called The Psychology of Selling and it's by Brian Tracy and he talks
about like, whenever we get done with a sale, we think that the prospect just, you know,
we get done off the zoom, Kyle calls me, he's like, hey, they're really excited.
And in our heads, we think that the person, the prospect is over there, you know, just
doing the pros and cons, thinking about joining, thinking about working with us on our lead
gen system, thinking about expanding all of Northwest Arkansas or all of Dallas, Fort
Worth and tree service.
And the reality is, dude, as soon as they hang, the reality is that they already made
up their minds is actually the truth.
But if they haven't, for some weird reason, the second they get off within five minutes,
they know that like what they're going to do or they know what it is on the call.
They're just looking for a reason or how to tell you how to do it.
And so, guys, what you need to understand.
And I'm going to say this like that, I'm going to say this very boldly because I've seen
it so many times.
This is not from theory.
This is not from reading books.
But I promise you, if you guys are just letting people think about it, letting people leave
you with their virtual card or either we're going to call you tomorrow, guys, it is, that
is literally, it is financial suicide, okay?
The prospect is not going to call you back.
The prospect is probably going to text you an hour later, five hours later, 24 hours
later, and they're going to send you some long message of why this isn't a good fit
for them.
They're going to hold off.
Okay?
The other thing that you don't realize is when you let the customer say, I'm going to
think about it, I'm going to get back with you, you are literally relinquishing all control.
You no longer have any control.
All you are now is a puppy dog that's following up with somebody who you're begging for money.
Okay?
So guys, when I started doing door-to-door sales, I kept getting this and I couldn't
figure it out.
I was like, I was not consistent closing.
I'd get to the end of the call and I would just cross my fingers.
I'm like, I would go for the close and if they did it, I was like, oh my gosh, thank
goodness.
If they didn't, then I didn't know what to do.
I tried all kinds of different stuff.
I was listening to Grant Cardone.
I tried to do these hard closing techniques.
And then guys, this is what changed everything for me is one day I was sitting in a training
and we had, I think I've told you guys this before, but we would do a training.
If you didn't sell the day before, you would have to go to this training where basically
you were shamed.
It was called the bagel meeting, right Kyle?
Which the bagel means you didn't sell.
And these bagel meetings, how many people would show up to these things?
I mean, it depended, but the energy was dog crap, right?
It's like all the people who didn't sell, that made no money, it's like imagine you
went all day, you knocked seven hours, eight hours of doors, and then they're like, you
have an extra meeting tomorrow at 10 a.m.
Dude, energy is like terrible.
So I'm in a training meeting one day, a sales training meeting, and our trainer, he proposed
this idea and he's like, I want to teach you guys this.
And he came up with this concept, he's like, I want you guys to have this mindset.
I want you guys to start implementing this thing where you say to people, and maybe whether
it's out loud or in your head, I don't do comebacks.
Or essentially meaning, I don't do, I want to think about it.
And I remember when he said that, I was like, yeah, right, bro.
Like there's no way, like, you know, I can think of all these different excuses.
Like you're asking me at 20, how old were you, Kyle, when he did this, do it in ourselves,
25?
Yeah, 25.
25, I think I was 23, 24.
Like you're asking me to ask 40, 50, 60 year old men, 30 year old men with huge houses,
like they have to make a decision, I don't do comebacks, like it was a really bold idea.
And I was like, there's no way I'm going to be able to do that.
But basically, the idea that he proposed to put in our head is that you get an answer
yes or no on the spot, and you'd rather take a no than you would a maybe, and that you
are bold with the customer and say, I do not do comebacks, okay?
So I know, Kyle, when I told you about this concept, I don't know if it was me, it could
have been one of our other managers.
Did you think that that was a crazy, crazy move?
Do you even remember when we came up with this, or did we just train you like that from
the beginning?
I don't even remember.
Yeah, that was just trained like from the beginning, but it was still a wild idea.
It's the same thing.
You're almost confronting these people and saying you have to be bold with your stuff.
It's hard.
Especially like it's much easier to where we're at.
This is why I'm always like, guys, you don't know how good you have it.
Imagine you go in like a little freaking puppy dog door to door in these big neighborhoods
with these giant houses with, you know, and Kyle, you were driving a Volkswagen Golf diesel
at the time.
You could barely fit in.
I was driving a Honda Civic or a Prius and like we're buzzing around neighborhoods, like,
you know, asking bold questions like this.
It was scary.
I remember when the guy said it, I was like, now I had all the objections in the world
in my head.
I'm like, now he's crazy.
I was like, in my head, I was like, well, what if the customer thinks it's high pressure?
You know, what if they think I'm a sleazy salesman?
What if the customer just says no and I lose the deal?
What if the customer kicks me out of the house?
And what if, what if, what if, what if, right?
These are all the things that you think.
And I remember he's like, if you will make up your mind and just follow this advice,
I promise you, you're going to close way more deals than you're going to lose.
And by the way, you are going to lose some deals.
I'm going to tell you guys right now, you are going to lose some deals doing this.
But guess what?
You're going to lose deals anyway.
You're going to lose deals.
This is sales, man.
So guys, this advice literally changed my life.
Like straight up literally changed my life.
And from that day, I can remember from that very day, I made the decision, the decision,
the decision, and I, it wasn't perfect at first.
It took me a minute to start implementing, but I was like, I have to change something
because I'm not, I'm not consistent.
I'm not closing deals and therefore I'm not making money.
And so I made the decision that I was going to do everything that I could that whenever
I got in a house at a closing table, the equivalent would be on a zoom call in the middle of a
negotiation.
It is a yes or no.
There is no maybe.
Okay.
If the prospect tells, says, Hey, you know, I'm going to have to think about it.
I'm going to get back to you.
That is a no for me.
Okay.
So, um, so guys, what I want to do today in the training, and I'm going to leave some
time for Q and A at the end, but in the training, I want to convince you as best as I can.
And yes, I do want to convince you.
I'm not going to leave it up to you to, to, to think for yourself.
You don't have to do this, but you're talking to two people that have closed a lot of deals
and we've been, we've, dude, Kyle, we have heard every excuse in the book.
Well, and I was, I was going to say the alternative, if you don't do it and the downside, if you
don't do it is you have this like mentality the next day that you're like, Oh, they told
me to come back about six o'clock and so you don't work as hard because you're like, you're
banking on that.
You're like, Oh, they're going to give me a note.
Then six o'clock rolls around, lights are off.
You see him peeking through the, you know, the thing and that's the same with this.
If you're telling the business owner, like, okay, they're going to think about it.
You're not going to go find another business owner in the meantime, but if you get a no
the next day, you're like, okay, I got to go find someone you're actually working where
you know the answer already.
So that's the problem is it gives you this false sense of hope, which then sets you back
further.
It's such a good point.
I can't tell you how many times I've gone home or let's say selling business owners.
I finished a day, got on two, two closing calls, didn't get it, but you know, the one
was like a nine out of 10.
They just had to check the books, they had to just check the finances and the other one,
he just had to check with his partner really quick.
And in my head, I'm like, I'm not going to say anything, but I should have two deals
by 12, 12 in the morning.
And then, you know, I'll hit the gym and really feel good about myself.
You wake up, first one's a text message that says, hey, we're not going to do it.
Second one says, we're going to hold off till the first of next year or we decided not to
go forward.
And now, like Kyle said, you didn't plan for the day properly.
You didn't have your mindset of like, hey, I got to go scrape, I got to go start over.
I got to go hook a new business owner.
You're sitting there going, I'm probably going to get it.
And it completely, it's a domino effect.
And I'm telling you guys, if you get off the call with somebody and they don't do the deal,
just go ahead and assume that it's a done deal, you're not going to get it.
Just assume that it's not going to happen because 90% of the time, you're not going
to get it.
Okay?
So, my goal in the next 15 minutes is I want to convince you guys that if you'll make up
your mind today that it is either a yes or a no, and then you will be strategic in how
you bring it up, because there is a way to do it right, there is a way to do it wrong.
I've done both, okay?
And I'm going to tell you what not to do.
If you'll do this, make up your mind, and just take a yes or no, you are going to close
way more deals than you're going to lose, okay?
And again, you are going to lose some because it's sales, okay?
So let's just go through this really quick.
I have five things I want to cover, is this.
So for this to be as effective as possible, guys, you have to set this up correctly or
you're just going to look like a slimy car salesman, which I admittedly have done before
because I haven't done this properly and you go in and you just, you don't, it doesn't
come across right, okay?
So number one, guys, you have to set the deal up correctly and you have to leave hints that
make sense why you're asking for the answer today, okay?
So I'm going to give you an example in door to door, I'll give you an example in this
business and then maybe if Kyle can think of one in door to door, I'll let him do it.
If not, I'll, I have one, okay?
In this business, one of the things I like to do is I like to plant the idea up front
to let people know, hey, I'm shopping this around.
I'm sending you leads, Mr. Business Owner, but, and I stole this from Jason Allred recently.
I love this one liner he uses, he says, hey, I'm sending you a couple leads, but I just
want you to know just to be completely upfront with you, I'm not exclusive with just you
yet.
I'm looking for the right partner in this area.
I'm not exclusive with you yet, okay?
So you know, letting them know you're working with other people and I'll throw stuff in
on my screencast, you know, hey, like I said, my goal is to work with the person that's
ready to move, the person that's hungry, and if that ends up being you, first, I want to
work with you.
I want you to, I do want to work with you, but if you're a maybe or I'm not sure, then
I got to move on.
I got ads running, if you want to say that, I've got leads coming in that are going to
waste, but you know, if you bring that up, it makes sense when you get to the end and
you say, hey, like, it's a yes or no for me, I got to have an answer.
Kyle, you just, yesterday, by the way, yesterday, me and Kyle, one of the things, as I said
in the beginning of this call, we're going back to the basics.
We're going back to the things that got us to success in the first place.
So yesterday, Kyle and I went over the sales call that he got on the sales call and we
didn't close it.
And Kyle, you had a really, really good one-liner that completely eliminated the objection of
I want to think about it.
You want to share that, dude?
It was so money.
It was clutch.
I love that.
Oh, I think, was it the hard pressure one?
Yeah.
So I just said, hey, this isn't going to be like a hard pressure, like door to door close.
Like this is really just to make sure you're going to be a good fit.
But with that being said, I am going to ask for a yes or no at the end.
And the guy was like, that sounds fair.
And you got a yes or no, it was a no, but at least you're not sitting there wondering
if it's a maybe, right?
And so, and we went through the pitch, we're going through it again today, but we realized
like that wasn't where he lost the deal.
We lost the deal at a different point that we didn't hit on.
But needless to say, we didn't, at least we got an answer.
And that to me, closure is the best thing in sales, okay?
One of the things we would do in door to door sales is we would let the customer know throughout
the pitch.
Yeah, so we're actually in the neighborhood.
We're here for the summer, but we're here in this specific part of town.
And so what we're doing is we're doing like this group thing where we're going to allow
the technician to come in and install these all at once.
So we don't have to be, you know, driving back and forth, whatever, something that makes
sense where it's like the technician's already in the area.
For those of you that have done sales, it doesn't, you're like, yeah, you can see that
from a mile away that that's complete BS.
But we at least came up with something that sounded like a good reason to say, hey, it's
now or never, okay?
So you got to have a reason.
And to bring it up at the last second, it doesn't work as well.
If you bring it up before and you're like, hey, I'm already working with, I'm looking
at this other guy, I'm going to give you the first chance here because I like you.
But I do want you to know upfront, I want to be completely transparent with you.
I am also talking to another one of your competitors.
I don't feel comfortable sharing the name or I don't care.
You guys can share the name if you want, but I am talking to one of your competitors.
I would love to work with you, right?
So then you get to the end of the call and you can say, hey, I already told you I'm talking
to somebody else.
If you don't want to do it, no problem.
But I'm not taking a maybe.
I'm talking to him today, right?
It's got to make sense.
So number one, guys, you have to set the deal up correctly.
You have to give a reason that when you ask for a yes or no, it makes sense.
You don't sound like a freaking knob, okay?
Secondly, guys, you need to be agreeable.
This is something Kyle's really good at.
So Kyle, like when people are like, hey, I want to think about it.
I need to talk to freaking my goldfish.
You're always really good at this.
What do you say right out the gate before you just go into a freaking objection overcoming
mode?
Yeah, I usually just say like, I agree with them.
Yeah, I get it.
Like it's a decision you got to make.
And then just ask like, typically, it usually is price with anybody, right?
Typically, it's the price.
So it's like, hey, aside from price, like what else do you like?
What are you wanting to think about exactly?
Yeah, 100%.
And I would even add on that.
So that's a really good guy.
Make sure you agree.
Hey, I feel you, man.
I take the pressure off.
I completely understand what you're saying.
I feel you.
And then the next thing, guys, step number three, you have to, like Kyle just said, he
jumped ahead.
You have to tie them down to the objection.
So you need to figure out what it is they actually need to think about.
So I think it can change.
I think price can come up.
It depends on what you're selling.
But I honestly think when selling business owners, I don't get with business owners specifically,
I don't get price as much because I've already gone through the screencast.
I've already showed them the lead value calculator.
And it is an investment that they're making that they're going to make their money back.
But you have to tie it down.
For example, if Kyle was my prospect, I'd say, Kyle, so just really quick, if you don't
mind me asking, I just want to get on the same page as you.
What exactly is it that you want to think about?
Yeah, I mean, I just kind of have this principle that I don't make same day decisions.
It's kind of been the thing that's got me to where I'm at in business.
I want to punch you in the face, Kyle.
That one is the worst.
And it's like, how do you argue with somebody that don't base principles?
OK, so let me ask this.
I'm assuming, Frank, I'll say Kyle, I'm assuming, Kyle, because of that, you got burned at some
point in the past.
And that's the reason why.
Like, is there something that I'm trying to dig a little bit.
So when did you get burned?
And he's going to tell me, well, I bought this car, blah, blah, blah.
So I'm going to say, so what do you think?
Like, obviously, if you were 100% certain about this and you knew that you were going
to get your money back, you were going to grow from this, it was going to be a good
partnership, you weren't worried I was going to scam you, this would be 100%.
Yes, there would be no doubt.
So I guess I'm just trying to figure out there's got to be a question.
I usually don't say there's got to be an objection.
You know, I don't like to put that in their head that they have an objection.
But what's your question, man?
Not to cut you off, but Kyle, you're already paying for Google Ads or you're already paying
for Home Advisor.
You already told me you're sick of them.
You already told me you want to grow this year.
I've already sent you five leads.
One of them you already closed, or if they haven't closed, don't say that.
You already know everything about me.
I've shown you what I've done for my, you know, whatever in the next town over.
So I understand what, and again, I'm saying this because I told you I'm already talking
to somebody else.
I'd like to see if we can make this work.
What is it that you want to think about?
And guys, you got to figure out what it is.
And if you push hard enough or you're strategic enough about like digging, you will get the
answer.
Well, you know, I just got to check because, well, like, yeah, I told you that we're making
30 grand a month.
However, we just had the engine in our car go out.
And guys, what you got to realize, especially with men, Kyle, tell me if I'm wrong, but
especially with men, we're so prideful.
We do not want to for one second tell them, like, I can't afford it.
Right.
Like, who wants to say, yeah, dude, money's tight.
I know I told you I was killing it.
I know my Instagram says I'm killing it, but I actually don't have 10 grand.
I actually don't have a thousand bucks a month.
Right.
And the reality is they're sitting there going, I don't have $500 to run on my credit card.
So you have to figure out what it is.
If you don't figure out what it is, guys, you're never going to get the deal.
So let's assume, Kyle, I've gotten past your stupid principle, which is just a smokescreen
anyway.
And you told me it's, let's just say it's something else because you don't get priced
as much when you're doing business.
Let's say that you told me, I don't know, what's another one we get all the time.
Let's say you got burned in the past or whatever.
You want to make sure that you want to talk to one of my clients.
Something like that.
Right.
So you got to tie the next thing, guys, you figure out what it is and you got to tie them
down to that objection.
So Kyle, besides wanting to make sure I'm legit, make sure that I'm not like these leads
that I sent you.
I didn't go and like, I don't know, I don't even know where I'd pull them from, but let's
say they're not a couple of my buddies from around town that are fake estimates that you
closed one of them.
Right.
I'm going to make it seem ridiculous.
Besides the fact you want to make sure I'm not a complete scam.
I'm not the Tinder swindler.
Is there anything else that doesn't make sense about this that would stop you from moving
forward today?
And then he'll say, yeah, no, if he says, yes, you need to figure out what it is.
Well, I also this, right.
And you got, and then once you say that, if they say, no, that's it, say, okay, now guys,
we've tied them, we've pushed them into a corner.
We've tied them into a corner.
We call it a tie down, right?
It's the same thing.
You can use the other analogy.
You're in a house in order to close the deal.
You need to completely seal.
You're in a room.
You need to completely seal it.
You have the door.
You have the windows.
You get three, four windows.
And each one of these objections, you need to close all of the windows and doors and
figure out where the leak is.
And if it's that one window that's price, that's it, but you got to make sure everything
else is closed.
Otherwise, as soon as you close the price window, then the freaking, I got to talk to
my goldfish over here or my wife because she's going to get mad at me.
That window opens, right?
You have to tie them down to one objection.
Okay.
Guys, and I was going to say one other thing.
I think it also comes back to like making sure you're qualifying people correctly.
Just because when you said that with the price, it just, you know, business owners, I've had
calls before where I've like, I've been so desperate just to pass off the leads to anybody
because I didn't want him to go to waste that I didn't qualify the business owners correctly.
So then when I got on the zoom call, I'm actually like, dude, this guy is like working out of
It's like him working out of his, you know, garage and like, he doesn't actually have
a legit company.
And so it's like, when I hit him with price, he's like, well, I could give you 250.
It's like, oh, I would have saved myself so much time if I actually would have qualified
him when I was getting him on the hook.
And that's part of the setup, you know.
That's a really good point.
That's, that kind of, that should, that's even before all of this, that's, we're assuming
with what we're talking about today that you've qualified correctly, but if you guys remembered
from my training, usually when you when you're losing the deal, it's usually the step or
two before.
OK, so if you're getting to the end of the call and you're getting this time and time
again, hey, I literally don't have money.
Like I'll show you my bank account and guys, I don't know about you, but I've had people
literally show me their bank account.
They're like, dude, no shame.
There's like seven dollars in there.
I've actually had that happen.
That's a qualification issue.
And no matter any of this stuff you do, you're not going to get around it.
Let's assume you qualify them correctly.
That's a really good point, Kyle.
Once you so just to review, you're going to make sure that you you you make it make sense.
You have something kind of jammed in there that's like, OK, it makes sense.
They ask for the deal.
Number two, you're agreeable.
Number three, you figure out exactly what the objection is and you tie them down.
Then what I like to do and Kyle's really good at this as well is you want to use the neighbors.
You want to use your other customers to close.
OK, it's way better when we say, hey, you remember Fred that I told you about that he
felt the exact same way that you feel.
And he's what he ended up thinking and realizing was this.
That sounds so much better than me coming at you and going, dude, you're stupid.
Why don't you understand this?
They can relate to Fred, who's another business owner that's a client of mine, way more than
they can relate to you.
And again, yesterday, Kyle and I are watching the sales call and he's done this so long,
he weaves in.
Anytime he has an opportunity, he was like, hey, have you heard of this person?
Let me tell you a little bit about them.
So now he's like, by the time the close comes, he's talked about three or four other people
who are already making money.
And he can come back and be like, hey, you remember that person I told you at the beginning?
Let me tell you about them.
When I went to close them, they were not ready to go at all.
They were the same thing as you.
They have a principle of 24 hours, whatever.
So guys, you want to sell through the neighbors, you want to sell to the business owners, and
you want to use them and use their story to explain how they, despite having doubts, were
able to make this decision.
Now, there's a method for this.
It's called feel, felt, found.
We don't have time to go into depth on that.
It's a completely separate training.
But I think inside of the, I'm almost positive, inside of the premium training library, premium
sales training library, for any of you that are paid in full, message Ashley.
If you're paid in full, you'll have access to the premium sales training library.
I think we have a video, maybe even a few, on the feel, felt, found method.
I'm almost 100% positive.
But you're going to sell through the customer, okay?
Example is this.
You know, hey, you remember that guy I told you about, Brooks?
The one I've been working with since 2020?
Funny enough, when he started, it was the exact same thing.
He was actually paying Home Advisor only like 300 bucks.
And for him, he was like having a hard time wrapping his head around tripling the price.
But then when he, what he said to me once we started talking about is he actually realized
that even though he was only paying 300 bucks a month, he was literally competing for every
one of these leads.
He was sharing these leads with three, four, five people.
So for every one of those leads, Home Advisor was actually charging triple.
So it was like, those leads were worth a thousand bucks a month, but he was only paying 300.
And that's why he wasn't closing any.
So for him, he's like, if I can close one deal from these exclusive leads, it makes
sense.
And that's why he decided to move forward.
Whatever it is, I would try to be more succinct than that.
I'm just coming up with something on the spot.
But use other people, other business owners, other deals that you've done, or other deals
that people have done inside of this group, if you don't have any deals yet, to go ahead
and overcome that objection that they have.
And then from there, guys, you can go back for the close, okay?
And so, guys, I'm telling you, if you will do this, and I'm going to end with one last
thing where you need to go for the close again, but if you guys will just make up your mind
to do a yes or no on every single call, you are going to close way more deals.
What it is, guys, think about it like this, you get to the end of the call, you have a
business owner that's sitting on the fence, right?
They could go yes, they could go no.
And I'm telling you, if you walk away from the deal, leaving them sitting on the fence,
the majority of them are going to tip on the side of no.
If you will be bold, if you will ask for an answer, if you will ask for a yes or no on
the call, you are going to tip a percentage of them that are leaning your way, you're
going to tip them on your side.
That nudge is going to get them on your side.
Kyle, we had a call, I was in Africa, what was this, two, three weeks ago, Kyle was on
a call.
We had an individual that was super interested and their objection was, were they about
to start school or something, you remember this?
I'm drawing a blank on who that was.
This person was about to start school, they were super interested and everything made
sense, blah, blah, blah.
I hopped on the call and basically reiterated what Kyle said, I'm like, hey, the reality
is because this person was like, I want to get to the new place, I want to get settled
and I'm going to have a better idea of my time.
I basically said to him, we tied him down and I said something to the extent of, here's
the reality, man, if we hang up this call, you already know the decision, whether you
get down there today, tomorrow, whatever, if you want to make this work, you're going
to make it work.
I don't know what your situation is going to look like, but I can tell you that if you
want to make this work, you are going to make it work because I've seen tons of other people
do it.
So let's do this.
I think what we ended up saying, we didn't even ask, we're like, I'm going to take a
thousand bucks down, the rest is going to be next week on this day and we're going to
get you going today.
And do you remember the guys like, okay, I think we can do that.
Do you remember what I'm talking about now?
Probably not because you do so many calls.
But anyway, I remember that call and all it took was like, hey, we're not doing that.
And if it's a no, if it's a I want to think about it, you're not our guy.
I want business owners that are like, and guys, it's true, man, business owners that
can make a fricking decision are business owners you want to work with, right?
If they're hum-hum around with you, they're not going to be closing fricking people that
want, that want their concrete services.
They're going to believe their stupid objections to a good salesperson is also somebody that's
confident in making a decision, okay?
The better I've gotten at sales, the easier it is for me to go and buy something on the
spot.
The easier it is for me to make a decision on, on whatever it is, whether it's a $20,000
program, whether it's buying a $220,000 G-Wagon off the lot without talking to my spouse.
I don't care because I'm like, I'm confident in making that decision because I know I can
go and make the money back or I can take the knowledge and make the money from that thing.
Okay, so just to review, you to make this effective, you have to put something in there
that makes sense, okay?
We're talking to other business owners.
Step number two, you have to be agreeable.
Step number three, you got to figure out what the objection is.
You got to tie them down, okay?
Step number four, you're going to use the neighbors.
You're going to use the neighbors meaning the customers, your other customers that you've
sold before.
And step number five, guys, is you're going to go back for the close, okay?
And you're going to say something like, so Brooks, like, or Bob, Kyle, like I told you,
you're in the exact same situation as him.
Nothing's going to change.
If I get off this call, the only thing that's going to change is I'm going to be going and
working with your competitor, which I don't want to see happen.
Everything makes sense.
You told me you want to grow.
You told me that you close at this percentage with this profit margin in this.
We did the numbers in the lead value calculator.
Price is not an issue.
There's nothing that's going to change from now to tomorrow.
Let's do this deal, man.
What, you want to put the Amex or Visa on file?
Let's do this, right?
And it doesn't have to be that bold.
You could say something else.
Kyle, how do you go back for the close after you've tried to do it and then you do it again?
What's your go-to?
I don't know.
It usually actually just kind of falls in place.
Like once you've kind of been like, well, you know, because even with the business owners,
you can be like, well, let's just do like a weekly deal, like a weekly payment.
Yeah.
So instead of like, yeah, fifteen hundred bucks a month, let's just do, you know, whatever
that is, two seventy five a week or three seventy five, whatever that comes out to.
And so almost a different like Amex or Visa, but like, OK, let's just do weekly versus
monthly.
But usually once you talk to them, usually they're just like, yeah, that makes sense.
Like let's just do it.
Yeah.
Kyle, you're using an assumption close just by doing it.
So Kyle, what he's saying, he's like, OK, so besides price, well, let's make this easy.
You said price.
And then when it comes to price, you want to dig in a little.
Are you talking about the, you know, the whatever?
I'm guessing the monthly chunk kind of scares you.
Let's make it easy.
I'll take this.
I'll split it up into four payments.
And then that's the way it's more digestible.
Sound fair?
Boom.
Done.
You got it.
That's the steps, guys.
The last thing I want to say is if they still are sitting there hum, hon, whatever, I would
say something to this extent, OK, this is something that I would use again and again
and again.
I would say something to the extent of this.
Look, sir.
Look, ma'am, I've been doing this a long time.
You've already told me you're unhappy with HomeAdvisor or Google Ads.
You told me you're interested in growing and you love the exclusivity of what I'm offering.
You said you've seen what I've done for Joe, for Jack, for Brooks, whatever.
And on top of that, I've sent you three leads for free.
And no disrespect, Kyle.
But if it doesn't make sense at this point and you're still like a maybe, I respectfully
I want to retract my offer, I'm a no.
Bold statements.
And you just be quiet.
And why do you do that, Kyle?
Explain what the psychology is behind that.
It basically just gets them thinking.
It's kind of the first person who speaks loses kind of deal, but it just makes them actually
make a decision instead of you jumping in and being like, oh, well, if you don't and
then it gives them an out.
So it basically takes the out away.
So if you go through all those steps and they're still like, hey, I still got to think about
it, then you got to go and you got to say what I just said.
And what you're doing, guys, is you're taking the control back.
You're like, OK, well, you know, if you're going to break up with me, by golly, I'm going
to be the first one to break up with you.
And you're like, you know what?
If you're a maybe, you're not my guy.
And the reason, guys, if you do that, what you're doing is you're taking the control
back.
But also, if they are actually this is the psychology.
If they were going to do it tonight or tomorrow or in three days, if you take the deal away,
if they were actually going to do it, if you retract the deal, I promise you they're going
to come with you.
And guess what?
The people that were never going to do it, you know what they're going to do?
That's the perfect out.
They're going to say, well, I guess I guess that's fair.
I had this happen yesterday.
We had a business owner, me and Francesca did this this proposal and they were hum-hum.
It was the sister that kiboshed the deal, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And finally, we were like, what should we do?
Should we try to hit him with something?
Get back on the phone.
I said, you know what?
Let's just see where they're actually at, because I was like, I don't think it's going
to work anywhere.
So you know what I did?
I did exactly that.
I did it over a text because it was just the situation and I sent him a text.
I said, hey, whatever.
I think his name was Brandon.
I said, Brandon, no offense, but we've been going back and forth.
It's like our third time doing this.
I feel like you're on board, but your sister, every time we talk to her, she just kills
the deal.
I said, respectfully, we're going to retract our offer.
And you know what he said?
He didn't say, okay, let's do it.
He said, I think that sounds fair.
Sorry, it couldn't work out.
The dude was never going to do it.
Imagine if we had been sitting there thinking, oh, this guy's going to call us and think
about it.
They're not going to do that, guys.
So if you get to the end, you go through the steps and they still are a maybe, you need
to withdraw.
You need to retract the offer.
I'm going to say that one more time, ma'am, sir, Kyle, look, I've been doing this a long
time.
Okay.
I've already, you've already told me you're unhappy with home advisor or whoever.
You told me you're interested in growing.
You told me you love the exclusivity of what I'm doing.
You've seen what I can do.
You've seen it with these other people.
I've shown you other projects I've done, and I've already sent you three leads for absolutely
free.
Have you had anyone else do that for you?
I don't think so.
At this point, if it still doesn't make sense, if you're still a maybe, I just don't think
this is going to be a good fit.
I want somebody that's confident in making a decision and wants to work.
You've told me everything that you're ready to go, but now you're hesitating.
Respectfully, if you can't say yes now, I think I'm going to have to go look elsewhere.
And it's scary the first time you say it.
But if they are on the fence leaning your direction, you're going to tip 90% of them.
And if you lose the deal right there, you are never going to get them anyway.
But what you've done is you've saved yourself an entire 24 hours, 48 hours, maybe a week
time thinking you're going to get a deal that you're not going to get.
You can wake up, you can get off the call, get pissed off for a second, go hook another
business owner and write that person off.
And I'm not saying to end it on a bad note.
I'm saying burn a bridge.
I'm saying retract the offer and move on.
Kyle, anything else I missed?
Well, one thing I was thinking about as you were talking that you do really well that
I don't do as well is calling people out on things that they've said.
So like with digital landlords, of course, we have it like, hey, can you make a decision
in the application?
And then we say that on the call.
And then when we get to the end, they're like, well, I got to make it, you know, I got to
think about it.
And I don't do as well as just calling them out on their bullshit and you do a really
good job.
Same thing with the business owners, like sometimes it's uncomfortable to call them
out when at the beginning, they're like, yeah, I'm hungry.
I'm looking to grow all this.
And then they get to the end, they're like, well, kind of hum-hulling.
Like that's when you can come back and be like, well, earlier you said you were hungry
to grow.
Like, were you just saying that just because it sounded cool or what?
That's something that it takes a little bit.
You're a lot more bold on that kind of stuff than I am.
But, you know, that's one thing tying them back to what they've said.
Yeah, we were going through the call yesterday.
And I think the person that we were, the call that we were reviewing early in the call,
the person said something like, I don't want to waste a bunch of time trying this on my
own.
Right?
I don't want to waste two years trying this on my own.
We get to the end of the call, or Kyle gets to the end of the call, and the guy's like,
he goes, well, I haven't really tried this on my own yet.
And it's like, well, you numb nuts, you said you weren't going to, you said you didn't
want to waste two years.
So now you want to waste two years.
Right?
And I get it.
It's uncomfortable.
But I promise you guys, you're not here to make friends.
You're not here to make friends with your business owners.
You can become friends, but you want them to respect you.
You're here to make them money.
If you can make them money, you will become lifelong friends.
Okay?
But letting them roll over you, not holding them to what they said, that's not going,
they're not going to respect you.
They're just, they're bulldozing you.
Okay?
And I'm not a big fan of the Cardone, hard close, blah, blah, blah, but I'm telling
you guys, this is how I want to end.
If you'll make up your mind today that you are no longer taking a maybe, it's a yes or
a no, I promise you, you will close more deals than you will lose.
100%.
Guys, there's a bunch of comments.
I apologize.
We couldn't get to them.
We were just ripping.
We're going.
Kyle, let's close some deals this week.
Guys, appreciate you being on.
We'll be on next Tuesday live, and we'll see you guys then.
Bye.